thank you
[Music]
do you guys know what uh Craigslist
misconnection yeah of course no I don't
know what is that so I actually posted
one one time no I'm a dead Spirit what
was it like not is it not as a bit not
as a bit so I was at this club this is
like [ __ ] forever ago
um and I I there was this girl across
from me and we were just kept on doing
the eyes thing right where it's like
it's like oh [ __ ] all right oh [ __ ] you
know what I mean and uh I gotta say this
boy has my coolest move
probably ever how old are you
um I was like 21 and just moved to LA
um but yeah I'm sitting there and dude I
S like this sounds like a [ __ ]
douchebag move but it worked right so
like she kept on mechanizing me and all
that stuff and then eventually I was
just I was just like hey
and she gets up and [ __ ] comes and
sits down next
how sick is that I don't think that's a
douchebag I couldn't even believe it
well it's kind of caught up and then she
walked away yeah
so then we were talking like everything
was cool and I think I was just so new
to like I never like
you know never been a pickup artist I've
never been a pickup artist were you
shocked that it worked I couldn't
believe it worked I couldn't believe it
um and then yeah because her area was
crowded mine I had an open seat so it
was like that made sense right it wasn't
just like I would have gone to her but
it was like that so then uh only
available to see so it's chivalry
alone yeah yeah he moves the bear I know
so then um we were talking and
everything but I had no [ __ ] ability
to like to even think about getting her
number or anything so then I think she
was like waiting like kind of like you
know like probably waiting and waiting
away and then you know her eventually
she has to go because her friend needs
to go and that was her ride and I was
like oh okay cool it was awesome meeting
you I was like [ __ ] yeah that was
awesome dude I was like that was [ __ ]
tight I was like what a move what a day
what a moment and then
the next thing I know I was like oh [ __ ]
I didn't give her [ __ ] phone number
and then yeah I was like what do I do
about that and then my my roommate at
the time he was like dude just go try
Craigslist Miss connections and so I
actually posted on there I was like hey
we met at this at this place your name
was your name is Rocky her name was
Rocky which is cool too and like I love
that cute chick named Rocky look let's
go and then um yeah so hit me up and
then you know obviously you got a bunch
of dudes some dick
is this Roxy
my dick's name's Rocky yeah those of you
don't know that's what misconnections
are it's a it's a stick photos yeah it's
a section on Craigslist where let's say
you met someone like this situation
forgot to get the number and you want to
get back in touch with them you just do
a post on Craigslist to the community
you kind of put a radius on the map of
where this happened what day and you say
Hey you were beautiful I didn't get your
number but find me here and you just
hope they see it yeah it's for dudes who
have no game dude that's what it is
because come on it's like 95 guys on
there I mean it's a pretty thin margin
because the other person would have to
be thinking of doing the same thing or
one of their best buds like let's say if
you go home like let's say the chick she
goes oh [ __ ] I didn't get his number
either and she's telling one of her
friends who's also a huge nerd and they
like to go on Craigslist and maybe hey
they called you out yeah yeah so sounds
like their nerdy friends would kind of
get along huh so it kind of just looks
like this where like you'll see like a
radius and then someone will just say
something yeah so we're gonna read a
bunch of misconnections that are up
right now today let's go just to see if
anybody can get the [ __ ] word and
we're gonna help get the word out we're
Amplified what's that girl Rocky
she's still looking married I'm sorry
the title is fit Bro My Fit bro
Hollywood what what's up a dude friend
yeah you're gonna you're gonna see a
trend shortly here goes oh what's up we
used to chill when your girlfriend was
out of town don't have your number I was
your fit Latin friend let's reconnect
dude they're busting it down is it is it
poor just connections though or like is
everything like with a sexual
connotation no no no some of these are
like actual like missed like love like I
saw you at a swim
Long Long Beach Boardwalk jogger girl
that's the title this is tight these are
my favorite ones we exchanged hellos
earlier friday-ish September 7th we met
again as I was talking with an elderly
lady I wanted to speak with you but I
didn't want to be rude I noticed you
were glowing we should talk wow
jogging in Long Beach
hit him up here's another weird one this
one says this is in Valley Village so it
could be you it says you were working in
my yard whoa so it could be you because
you know what I'm doing is throwing food
over them your locations Colleen's got
the headphones in the leaf blower yeah
I'm mowing along it's really weird he
goes you were working in my yard I was
the guy in the den watching whoa you
knew what I was doing yeah this sounds
familiar I was hoping you'd come and
join me oh God what was he doing though
this guy doesn't know he's a [ __ ]
creeper he has a [ __ ] creepo dude he
probably wrote that was like yo this is
tight I'm gonna turn around so bad he's
like should I just say that I was
jerking on the glass
no I'll leave that out I gotta be
mysterious right be mysterious what I
was doing two guys just workshop with it
like uh should I leave it in I'll take
it this one's a good one it's uh it's
from a McDonald's drive-through in
Culver City oh yeah and the guy goes I
was on a bike you helped me order food
because they don't serve people riding
bikes I wish we had exchanged contact
info hope I see you again you said I
hope so too and hope you see this post I
hope they reconnect that's innocent
that's nice there's sad people out there
missed opportunities dude yeah super
remembering to ask for phone number yeah
I want to know the success rate on this
is what do you think the success rate is
for this one I think it's low as [ __ ]
I I think it never happened
while you're like pre-framing I think is
pretty successful guy at the Shell gas
station in Santa Clarita says
to the guy at the Shell station near
Sierra and Princesa you were wearing
black shorts and flip-flops pumping your
gas I gave you a glance down your shorts
and you noticed I was the chubby Latin
guy with the beard wish you followed me
home to my place I was nearby and wanted
to be on my knees for you
hey shoot your shot shoot your shot
that's good
what is
this
person
most of these are
these are Big I live around the corner
because here here is like the platform
is cool there's like sexual harassment
yeah true yeah true that's so far that's
not bad this one might be for me it says
missing my Filipino young friend oh it
sounds like you from Woodland Hills he
said yeah yeah I'm sorry he goes my
Filipino friend we met a few times the
past four months I enjoyed you I left to
London six weeks ago for a project you
told me you will come with me next time
I go to London when I came back from
London I could not find your phone
number I am looking for you oh he got
ghosted how does that happen how does it
happen if they bust it down already and
then they just don't exchange contact I
honestly think somebody like [ __ ]
deleted their phone and had T-Mobile
delete their number and [ __ ] that's what
that sounds like you dude some of these
are like I couldn't find your number
weird yeah that's interesting so to sum
it up majority of the misconnection
you're going to find on Craigslist are
pretty creepy they're pretty weird yep
yeah sounds like a bunch of dudes just
trying to talk like like shoot their
shot late too late basically them are
dudes for dudes
I started to pick up with that on the
first one but I feel like I'm also
thinking Craigslist isn't really a chick
Place full of dudes there also though
you gotta think though you know hang out
on Craigslist no yeah I think that
segment's pretty true you don't look for
services on Craigslist just go there and
you're bored like you just it's like
Pinterest you just check it out I think
The Craigslist Killer like ruined it for
like women for sure I agree oh you think
he did yeah it was the movie that they
made on but that means the success rate
is probably higher than we all think
because a guy would think to write that
then maybe a guy would think to read
them and find it yeah yeah that's a
really good point I just think it's more
like like grinder for example right like
uh guys you get it like guys always want
sex first so with gay guys it's just
double the chances of sex quick forget
to get the contact and they speak the
same language yeah you know what I mean
so it's like hey let's get to it because
that's what I want and I don't have to
like work up to it because I know you
wanted to similar like frame of mind you
know what I'm saying so I would guess
that more people would be looking on
there because guys know about it or guys
are willing to post
you ever feel like you had a
disconnection in your life and went on
Craigslist and found my Craigslist aside
just life Missed Connections in live I
mean
yeah I think everybody has like a really
like Steve you know like a really cool
connection one time but what did you do
though yeah did you follow up I didn't
know about Craigslist I had to try I
love that he used the sexual thing you
know we had when we might lose this
story go go loser let me finish my
[ __ ] thought too late too late we had
Facebook
remember remember when you would like we
just got Facebook mainly for we went to
you went to the university yeah yeah so
like but that was a huge thing you
because at University you might have
like talked to somebody but they might
not have given you a phone number it
might have been passing might have been
class you meet some in class all the
time but you're not gonna ask for the
number right now for you young man
for you what if you're in Auditorium
it's like hello students you're not
gonna sit next to the same people all
the time but then on Facebook you were
immediately looking up people to do
exactly that oh that's true and then you
could like poke them remember that [ __ ]
okay yeah oh yeah did you like that that
was our Craigslist oh no girl liked that
nobody liked it super Pokemon right
yeah that's where you go to Craigslist
for yeah that's true Super Ultra Mega
Poke now I want to hear your story go
ahead so this is before Facebook because
I'm not a [ __ ] young man like Anthony
and uh I remember specifically because
it was one of the most where I'm like
I'm a [ __ ] simp
but I have to do it no matter what so me
uh
we we got uh
me and Joe actually got booked to do
this club gig as Uncle Sam and Uncle
chin a club a club gig I don't know why
they wanted us there but we were there
and this is a Joy Luck Club and this is
when like import models were still like
a thing so it was like a uh it's that
era right so it's like probably my space
was coming down Facebook was probably
only for colleges still that that era
and I had the ice thing with the girl
and I was like oh it's for Halloween and
I was like Pocahontas why are you
looking at me like that and then the
whole night I was trying to get closer
to talk to her but I couldn't and
because I'll have to do my [ __ ]
uncle's emotion clumpy so half the half
the night I'm in this [ __ ] like pink
like white pole the better shirt thing
and then the other half of them like
regular clothes off this change in and
out so I have to go to the DJ booth and
announce things like Mrs Doubtfire dude
yeah
Vietnamese accents and [ __ ] oh God so I
didn't really get a chance to like uh
something I'm working a gig right so I
don't really get a chance to just go out
and mingle and talk yeah but we did have
the ice thing a couple times and it's
when I got back home I was like [ __ ] I
wish you have to go find her and we
didn't really have Facebook but I was
like oh yeah because remember back in
those uh back in those days like all the
Asian clubs they always had that
photographer and it goes on the website
oh that's so so I was just [ __ ] loser
like certain page after page after page
after page and I I swore I probably
searched from like 2 A.M until 6 A.M
and then even ones I'm like is that the
back of her head
no that's not Pocahontas they keep going
and going and going on and then
afterwards I didn't find her and I was
like damn I'm a [ __ ] loser and I went
to sleep and meanwhile this
try it again Pocahontas is just there
and she's like this is this [ __ ] guy
in the wig staring at me a bunch
dude there was like a couple there was
like Zoom X was one of them and they
were like websites that covered all the
clubs there's like one of those ones and
they would have like 50 pages of photos
from just one club night because it was
just walking around groups and there's
like hey they're just taking pictures
like the whole night everywhere and
there's always that group photo of the
dudes [ __ ] rolling he's just like
yeah dude you could probably find old
photos of Joe and some of them shits we
did find one the other the other week
yeah did you really yeah Joe was like
hella looking for like an hour I found
it
of course Joe would look for an hour too
yeah while we're filming yeah yeah yeah
yeah he takes seven videos off to look
for
[Music]